[Music]
tonight two Governors get the chance to
settle one of the biggest political
debates which state does it best
Florida's Ronda Sanz and California's
Gavin Newsome facing off in the red
versus blue Showdown we've all been
waiting for Sean Hannity moderating the
big event tonight at 900m Eastern it's a
chance for the high-profile leaders to
reshape the political landscape and
cement their status as the future of
their political parties the pair have
been trading shots for months over who
runs their state better what he's done
in California governor Nome causing a
mass Exodus out of the state you really
seen cities collapse there that is what
he would want to do for this entire
country I'd tell him to pack up and and
wait a few years and actually do some of
the hard work which actually includes
governing not just identity and culture
War we will never ever surrender to the
woke mob our state is where woke goes to
die human beings used as pwns for a
Guy's political advancement that's
pretty sad and pathetic but it's not
just policy the two Governors have been
exchanging plenty of personal insults
too stop footing around are you
going to throw your hat in the ring and
challenge uh Joe are you going to get in
and do it or are you just going to sit
on the sidelines and Chirp he's just
weakness masquerading his strength yeah
he's flailing but I think what
California represents it's it's kind of
the leftist petri dish I remember
growing up and folks would have their
mouths washed out with soap if they
talked like
this Jesse I imagine that might have
been something you dealt with I did once
had my mouth washed out with soap never
again never again so are you ready for
tonight I am I'm really excited you know
when you go out to dinner Dana and you
order your appetizer and your entree and
all of a sudden the waitress comes out
with a surprise compliments of the chef
I wasn't expecting this this is great
this is before an election year we're
getting a debate like this so Dan santis
has an opportunity to separate himself
from the pack he's been languishing but
this is a really good chance for him
because it plays to his strength he's
not one of those Republicans that likes
to attack other Republicans like a V or
a trump or a Christie he hasn't really
engaged like that he likes the
confrontation he likes the conflict
whether it's the press or another
Democrat and you can't have a bigger
contrast than this these two States
could not be any more opposite so you're
going to get not as much personal stuff
that we've been hearing you're going to
get a good policy contrast and as you
said you're going to see what works and
what doesn't his challenge is going to
be tell the story because his story is a
better story stick to it sell it but you
can't let Nome be Charming you have to
turn his charm into sleeves and it's a
difficult task but no one trusts a sleev
bag now news has a different
option Nome has to be good but he can't
be too good what I mean is Nome has to
be good so he has to establish himself
as the a parent as the alternative in
case something happens to Joe and then
definitely in 2028 but if he's too good
Dana then you're going to see donors and
pundits start drafting him and telling
Joe Biden to clip the campaign and
that's going to create a war and I don't
think the Democratic party wants that
right now Nome though has to not only
defend California's record he has to
defend Joe Biden's record so that's a
little tricky so if I were to santis I'd
try to jam him and try to make him
defend Joe Biden because Nome has to
acknowledge things are rough right now
and he has to do it in a way that's
honest but also not attack Joe Biden but
say this is how I'm different than Joe
Biden he's going to take a lot of
agility to do that the guy's slick he's
going to come out with a lot of facts
Anything could happen I'm really really
excited me too the facts for Florida
seem to be if you're looking at just raw
facts that the outcomes in Florida are
better than California yeah the numbers
look really strong for uh for Florida I
mean here here are some of them
California lost 55.7 billion in income
Florida gained uh 80 billion in income
unemployment it's half of what uh
California's at 4% Florida's at 2
2.6% C national average on gas is below
the national average California $485
sents good luck hunting for that now I I
I asked president Trump what he thought
and will he be watching he will be
watching he says hope they have a great
evening and wish them well for 28 so
that's so that's where he stands I do
find this the way you were describing it
is like the way you feel before a fight
you can't wait to see what Tyson's going
to do what Holyfield's going to do you
can't imagine what it's like to see him
together you know like a part and what
I'm most intrigued about Dana is this is
a real debate because if you look at the
Democrat or Republican debate both sides
agree with 85% of what they said so they
got to find a Nuance something about
their background some hypocrisy here
it's like no no uh this is what I feel
about social issues this is what I think
about social spending this is how I feel
about schooling so they're going to be
dramatically different and it's it's
going to be almost uh cathartic to see
it hashed out aside from this table uh
upstairs on the couch but actually in
front of a national audience and Harold
do you think this is a chance for Nome
to set himself apart and become that era
parent no matter what happens it
probably probably or are you going to
challenge him no it's it's going to be
back around hope everybody had a good
weekend I I agree with just about
everything that's been said I do think
that Jesse's point and I love Brian but
Jesse's point about how I think Governor
Nome is not going to be careful but he
has to understand and if he performs
well tonight you're certainly gonna
it'll be a catalyst for even more people
to say they want they want I don't think
so I think but I do think out of out of
fairness I throw the game I think Jesse
was trying to make make that point two
um both of these guys are emblematic of
consistent with that the state of the
parties uh both parties if you look at
the data on both sides if you ask
primary voters most primary voters on
the Republican side want someone other
than the front run on the Republican
side who's Mr Trump same is true with Mr
Biden Democrats want someone other than
two or three it's clear that if the
santis were performing as well as
everyone thought he was going to perform
four months ago he probably would not be
doing this debate I mean he needs this
he needs this rep before the voters and
for Nome he certainly wants to make
clear that if he's not going to be the
person in 24 which doesn't look like
likely that he will be the person in 28
he'll have that opportunity the two of
them come from great States great
economies good weather in both of them
uh on you look the next last four don't
you see the deficit in California but I
mean but people would you you PLL
America they would love to live in Los
Angeles love to live on a beach in
Malibu I hear saying both of them have
issues now Newsome has a crime in
homelessness issue he's going to have to
address the santis has an issue around
public education and Home Insurance
problems and insurance prices going up
in the state and what he's what he's
done to address that in addition Mr Dan
santis has actually been out on the
campaign Trail nationally because he's
running for office for president and
he's had a chance to lay out his vision
and that vision is supported by what
he's done in Florida and he seems now to
be slipping in the polling data Miss
Haley now seems to be the alternative
for Mr Trump I'm going to watch tonight
I'm Sean has done a great job FR I'll be
on a little after comment on it but I'm
going to be interested to see not only
how they go personally at it Jesse said
it best but how they talk about their
Visions in their state and you said as
well and how they might lead the country
because that's what people are going to
be looking at I mean people who don't
live in Florida California which is
going to be a majority of the Watchers
and viewers they want to see if these
two guys could lead the country and
we'll get an opportunity tonight to see
first grabs at it first stand it is
pretty incredible that Sean Hannity had
the idea was able to pull it together
he's a perfect moderator for this moment
a great interviewer knows the issues
very well and there's no audience yeah
which will give both candidat not not
candidates both Debaters a chance to
talk without too much Interruption I
imagine is this important moment for Dan
santis for the 2024 campaign I think it
could be um but I'm actually I know that
2024 is like the big talk in 2028 but
I'm actually watching this just from the
perspective of governance and the kind
of governing that we have in this
country you know we have 50 different
states with 50 different Governors and
different ways of people doing things
California is a place where is a number
one place where people are moving out
Florida is the number one place moving
in California used to be governed by
Ronald Reagan who of course went on to
be one of the best presidents we've ever
had uh I I like that we're going to see
two major political parties go at it
from a state perspective an executive
level uh from the states to talk about
the way that they govern and what they
think is best for their people and how
that can be emulated on the the federal
level we see this a lot with Senators on
the senate floor we don't get to see
Governors going at it oneon-one together
very often Florida and California have
bigger economies than most countries in
the rest of the world there are
obviously big differences between
California and Florida um but I'm really
excited to see just the debate aspect of
this and to have a longer conversation
between two people who are you know very
popular in these places Gavin Newsome of
course was recalled tried to be recalled
he came out politically stronger he's
very charismatic uh and I think that
Rhonda San to have quite the things to
handle tonight because he's he's a tough
debater for sure hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else